David last time we were talking about
the beginning of Romans and we saw that
Paul had sketched the universal problem
of human sin and had suggested that God
had through Christ
solved that problem by giving a gracious
act of forgiveness and connected somehow
with the death of Christ and then in a
peculiar way he concludes chapter 3 by
saying do we then overthrow the law by
this faith through which we now relate
to God and he says by no means on the
contrary
we uphold the law which seems to be a
almost another thesis statement it
hugely to be exactly governing this next
section of Romans that this is a right
reading of the law not an overcoming of
the law right so he begins then in
chapter 4 by calling on Abraham what's
going on here and how is he reading
Scripture
well the way I read it and I'd love to
get your response to this is that that
Abraham becomes an extraordinarily
important figure for him because Abraham
provides for Paul what he needs he
provides a way of being made right with
God apart from the law and it's not
because Abraham's not a Jew he knows
he's a Jew it's because Abraham believes
prior not only to Moses and the giving
of the law but prior to Abraham's own
circumcision and so he can he can take
Abraham in chapter 15 as the example of
chapter 15 of Genesis sorry
take take Abraham in Chapter 15 of
Genesis as a model of the kind of person
who by faith is made right with God not
by obedience to the law even though
later Abraham will become law obedient
so far he hasn't done so and God still
makes Abraham right with God's own self
mm-hmm so in effect Paul is is offering
us a strong should we call it miss
reading or wrong miss reading a strong
rereading Paul would I oughta tell my
students Paul would never pass an Old
Testament course today because he
entirely ignores what we think of as the
original context and moves it quickly
into a kind of Christian context I think
for Abraham Paul's the first question
that that he does what Christian people
are supposed to do which is to trust in
God by faith and that in some ways his
faith precedes but also
prefigures Christian faith because it
trusts in the God who can bring forth
God's promises against death and against
destruction okay so in some ways Abraham
is a type of faith so Abraham is a type
of faith and he provides a scriptural
warrant for Paul's claims about faith
being the way in which we relate to God
exactly this argument had been used by
Paul once before right in Galatians
collations yeah does he modify it at all
I think in Galatians it's much more
complicated and allegorical and plays
with a whole range of kind of not very
convincing proof texts about how Abraham
relates to Christ I think I think he's
honed it here so that Abraham now
becomes a prefiguring of the believer in
a kind of consistent way and that that
Gentiles and Jews alike are supposed to
be able to read the story of Abraham and
say AHA that's me I recognize myself in
that story I think it I think it has
considerable rhetorical power
yeah I'm struck by that difference
between Romans four and Galatians three
yeah on a couple of points there's a
verse that Paul quotes here and romans 4
verse 7 it's from from the SAMS right 32
blessed are those whose iniquities are
forgiven and whose sins are covered
blessed is the one against whom the Lord
will not reconcile which picks up
precisely the theme that he had
mentioned in the previous chapter
exactly how does exactly and he sees
that somehow exemplified through the
story of Abraham yeah he knows at the
same point in in Galatians 3 there's as
you point out a rather obscure use of
scriptural text I'll talk about the way
in which Christ death is somehow a
substitutionary yes and and he the other
thing he does there as you know is he he
plays on the words so that in Genesis
15:6 it says abraham believed in God and
it was reckoned to him as righteousness
and then he picks up the son blessed is
the one against whom the Lord will not
reckon sin so he does a kind of
concordance thing what are great texts
on God's reckoning and God's reckoning
doesn't have to do with the law any
longer it has to do with the
righteousness of faith mm-hmm say a
little bit about this notion of
reckoning and what kind of image Paul is
using here to think about the gospel and
yeah well my sense is that
that reckoning partly is judicial
language and that it has to do with the
way in which one's transgressions are
counted are not counted and that that
God as a kind of judge instead of
reckoning ones transgressions against
one instead reckons Christ's
righteousness as being the way in which
the faithful are made righteous he
doesn't go into that in great detail but
I think he's hinting at that kind of
that kind of claim I want to go back to
something you said a little bit the last
time because I think you're right on on
this I think we try to read Paul as if
he had an elaborate version of the
doctrine of atonement and I think what
he has is a lot of proof texts and
metaphors and images and topologies all
of which want to say that it is in
Christ that we are made right with God
but I don't think you can write any of
them to a kind of a full-blown
soteriology full-blown doctrine of
salvation because he's not doing
full-blown doctrines he's doing
metaphors and images and homiletically
aims but it is interesting to think how
the whole of the Christian theological
tradition has picked up on so it's
usually is that right to make them
consist a fertile area and I don't think
it works so well with Paul I think I
think he's an ad hoc theologian maybe we
should think just a little bit about the
the second part of Paul's argument here
in chapter 4 where he goes into the seed
of Abraham yes I have residents and some
of other well certainly in in Galatians
Paul has decided that Jesus is the seed
of Abraham for the complicated reason
that in the text the word seed is in the
singular and Paul in a strong Mis
reading of the text assumes that means
that when God promises Abraham to have
seed he must mean a seed not seed in
general and the a seed singular seed has
got to be one man and the one man has
got to be Jesus he's moved away from
that I think overly fancy way of
interpreting in here and it becomes the
seed of Abraham now becomes those who
have faith in the model of Abraham's
faith and and therefore Abraham becomes
the father of the faithful not in quite
the same way the father of the one seed
Jesus Christ it's it's smarter theology
I think yeah and he's also able to
introduce the theme of resurrection
very much so
cause I see it and you may you can help
me on this as I see it the story of
Abraham and Sarah becomes itself a
prefiguration of resurrection right that
Abraham is as good as dead in terms of
begetting a child and Sarah's as good as
dead in terms of burying one and what
they bring forth out of nothing a child
or out of their death - a new life
that's resurrection and therefore
interestingly what Abraham already
believes is resurrection and in that
sense he already pre believes in Jesus
this type of logic this type of logic
again we're going fascinating argument
it's a terrific argument